okay so so today we're going to start a
new moral we're really shifting gears
here because this one is starting from a
somewhat different standpoint than the
other moral theories of whether we're
going to study a lot of the moral
theories that we've been looking at
would ask you questions like what is it
that you really desire what is it that
really motivates you and are you
pursuing that internationally so you
know if you're heating this what is it
that you deep down in your soul desire
like everybody else pleasure or the
absence of pain and if you think things
through you'll realize that that's
really what you've been after the
rational thing to do is to arrange your
life
and your active choices in such a way
that you obtain the maximum of pleasure
than pain if you're if you're
utilitarian you expand that so that
you're looking at everyone's right so
it's not just you it's other people if
you're a virtue ethicist and you realize
that what's really going to make you
fulfilled is being a just person a
courageous person developing your your
qualities of character developing your
human potential well then you know the
rational thing to do is to pursue that
if you're an egoist we're going
backwards now a little bit and you say
well you know I just want to pursue my
own interests everybody's out to pursue
their own interest that's what the good
is satisfying my desires figure out
bless you figure out what your desires
are and then pursue them right maybe you
don't actually know when you start like
your desires are probably all done
through some exercises where you what's
called Values Clarification where you
have to write down on a piece of paper
what it is that you think you want and
then somebody talks with you about it
asks you some questions you realize oh
that's not what I really want is the
thing that doing that's going to get
like if I say why are you here in class
today and you say well because otherwise
I'm not going to pass the class is
passing the class you're your ultimate
goal in life no you want to graduate you
want to graduate for its own sake no
you'd like to get a job why do you want
a job you have to make some money and
you'd like to be fulfilled well it's
those things that you really want isn't
alternate with cons and with the
anthology in general but especially with
cond we're shifting gears all that sort
of stuff is in place we have once we
have desires we have what he calls
inclinations we do desire happiness we
naturally tend to try to pursue it but
that's the sides of point pursuing Duty
pursuing the characteristic of having a
good will will that's aligned with duty
and not motivated by by other
inclinations or other motives is the
good for a deontologist and I want to
talk just a little bit about this this
term Bant ology before we look at a few
instances and start going further into
this so it's coming from a great work
like a lot of the things that ethics do
and the Deo is coming from a word that
that means something like obligation or
thinking that is a must brush it if you
say day in ancient Greek and then is it
with a verb or something like that
you're you're doing something like what
they used to call that when you
kids helping verbs sometimes they still
do that language arts called modal verbs
and other languages it shows that
there's some sort of necessity there
some sort of requirement and that's what
the anthology is about the kind of
requirement or necessity that we're
thinking about is a moral requirement or
necessity it should and walk - not a
must as in if I drop this pen what's
going to happen it's going to float
let's go let's go right we think it's
going to fall under time if I drop it it
doesn't fall you're going to start
looking for hidden wires or things like
that right we would say it must fall or
you might say it should fall all right
watch the fall if this pen doesn't
follow there's something wrong with the
pen Beurling is it a bad pen should we
punish it no because it's it's a penance
an inanimate object we talked about you
know things is being good or bad in
different ways it's a good penny that I
write with it when it quits you know
rolling the ink out where I wanted to I
want to throw it away because that's the
only value that it has with a human
being
perv r-value resides in our being able
to follow a different kind of law or
rule moral laws so we're way beyond this
or even you know even something like
this imagine that we we do the sort of
sort of science fiction speculative
fantasy kind of thing and eventually
this can become a sentient being or
sulfa that's not unreasonable I mean
think about how how far things have
advanced just in our own time used to
that computers were pretty big I'm not
from the era you know room size
computers but I knew people who remember
that this would have been amazing back
when I was your age the fact that was
hooked up to the World Wide Web and it's
got all these these powers and
capacities maybe they'll be something
like this self-aware it's probably not
going to be a moral agent like we are
though I'm not sure if you can actually
get across to a computer or robot or
some sort of artificial intelligence the
notion of right and wrong you can get
across that it has to do things in place
but that if want to choose the right
thing and avoid the wrong thing that's
unique to us you know it's not just
animals that we differ from it's all
there things that could be like us
things that are being modeled after us
that that we would be different from so
the anthology you know whenever there's
an ology was that always being remember
studying right so the study of our
duties study is what we watch me do it
Kannada is probably the most important
philosopher associated with this is idea
but you can see it running through a lot
of different attitudes and it doesn't
always have to be so theoretically work
down in this contest up well we're going
to plow through over the next three
class sessions you can talk about sort
of a naive sense of duty where somebody
is Duty driven they've never really
thought deeply about it they just feel
that they always want to act in
accordance with their duties and these
are the kind of people who will you know
rely on
they will not be moved by say their
desires desire delight
to make money and desire to win
friendship or romantic relationship or
things like that they'll do what they
want to do or at least what they think
that they don't have to do whether it
benefits them or harms them sometimes
even whether it benefits other people
are harms up because we just worry about
whether there's another duty there to
harm other people and you know you've
encountered this before think about
stoicism we talked about that being
associated with same military people if
you're a soldier and you're in war doing
your duty and sticking to your duty has
a good chance of getting you killed
we're made or required you to face
terrible odds or fears you know undergo
a lot of horrific experiences somebody
could say well look that's what I have
to do that's my duty what makes me a
good soldier is if I fulfill my duty and
the same thing you go for other
professions as well think about
firefighters or our fleets prison guards
we've talked about that before other
people have duties like that
guide their life guide their practice
what about doctors and nurses we're EMTs
they have to make a lot of difficult
decisions sometimes have to tell people
things they don't want to hear they have
to be even ways that they don't really
feel like behavior you know unless you
really get to blood there are some
people that way cutting people open or
you know starching a womb it's probably
not that much fun you can say they're
motivated by the feeling satisfaction
but what happens when that goes away
what happens and they get burnt out
people do get burnt out jobs don't think
so if you can convert down at one time
you may burnt out actually out of school
by the time that I was where are you
guys
I was already starting to get what they
call senioritis but I stuck with it and
you probably are sticking with that
perhaps motivated by this sense that
well I've made it commitments and I have
to follow through on that commitment
maybe you think of yourself as having a
duty to yourself or to the school or to
your parents or to somebody else that's
is sort of non philosophical but you
know philosophically respectable I think
way of looking at duty I think you can
acknowledge is a good thing right
somebody who is motivated by duty
getting a person motivated by duty is
better say that a person who's just out
to get whatever
what do you let's take a phone and you
have to decide one or the other so we'll
start with the the maybe the more
attractive thing for ourselves and it's
that times the person who just actively
goes the person have just acts to
maximize their own satisfaction of
desires another person
anybody think they're it's okay if you
do what about the person who stinks to
they're doing even if it doesn't satisfy
the desires better person some of you
are uncertain notice though buddy after
class raise their hand for Purdue we do
tend to see this as a good thing going
Honda's is on to something and thinking
about this Conte is the guy we're going
to look at first and then we're going to
look at WT Ross Ross was actually a
little bit easier to understand so you
might say why did you put him after the
contact are you cracking our heads with
with this complicated stuff when Ross in
some ways makes it simpler well Ross is
just not as profound as Cody and I want
to confront you with the contrast
between this kind of moral theory and
the other cat's walk through the looking
when we look at an easier one
and here's what I want to stress to you
there's a lot of times calm kids
portrayed as just being this really sour
Duty for its own sake everything else is
terrible nothing else is good you know
the only thing that matters is that you
do your duty and you can make your will
conform to do is that saying that the
only good thing is do or a good row he's
saying that that's what the best things
and that other things if they have to be
sacrificed for that that's that's a good
thing
so I put up a list here of different
things that he says are goods or
boundaries on happiness for example all
of you want to be happy right
is happiness look exactly the same for
each one of us probably are there some
general traits does anyone want to be
sick it's a pretty happiness for you
does anyone want to be poor like you
dirt poor not just like I'll have a
small apartment or no car dirt born no
does anybody want to isolate it not have
any friends so you want there are
certain elements of happiness right and
you know we don't want exactly the same
I may want different things in my
friends than you do each one of you
probably want different things
you're not even the same one day to the
next sometimes right but you know
happiness is a good thing constant
saying it is happiness by the way he
says the satisfaction of all of our
desires and informations our feelings of
death count is often portrayed as saying
Duty is the only important thing you
find that with pure reason if your
feelings are involved that contaminates
think about all your different kinds of
feelings I think some of the feelings
that you have to think you would say has
something to do
being a good person should a good person
feel certain things what do you think
it's one thing to have it on an
intellectual level and think out how is
this going to affect other people like
the utilitarian right it's another thing
to actually care about other people you
might say the head versus the the heart
I think we'd all see that as a good
thing don't caring about other people
any of anything else's and other kinds
of feelings that are good to make
personal good person
whatever goes beyond sharing
that's probably important yeah a sense
of sense of shame or guilt when you do
something wrong I think we would say
that somebody who doesn't ever feel that
there's there's something really wrong
by the way there's a name for people who
don't have a sense of any sort of
negative when they do something wrong
call them sociopaths in the state's far
away from those people as possible
angels well let's think about what goes
beyond carrying us there any other
emotions that we feel towards other
people everything are good maybe you
want to feel what other people say
towards your spouse god you're very
something you probably nothing to fight
with them if not why'd you marry in the
first place right
yeah sympathy sensitive sympathy towards
those who are suffering that's that's a
good one yeah at Murray that's
interesting you would say collector is
your sponsor it's a good thing you're
right feeling a sense of admiration
particularly when it's admiring the
right people right if you're somebody
asks you who's your list of heroes and
you say whole pas Hitler Stalin there
then there's there's a compliment but if
it's you know if it's if it's other
people other charissa the I have all
sorts of
I'm good here so far oh I was relative
here we only made two and you made like
five patents well they're they're not
taking the good here oh that's it
are they going to technically ban heroes
elevated scale see my heroes are people
go he's a very brave a sore the keys
what else
what a love what was a good thing I am
going to be good me towards the wrong
people you know if you're if you're love
about Hitler got to do what he did
that's probably not good in general we
save long as we did there is kind of
saying that these sort of feelings that
might motivate us are bad that he's not
saying they're bad thing he's just
saying that's not enough that's not the
principal morality good character traits
are good character traits enough they
were in virtue ethics but they're not
for common reasons that we'll see I love
you know things like pleasure and health
well honor again he's not saying these
are bad things he's not a pessimist he's
not painting the world black except for
you know this tiny little sliver of
light here that comes in from the one
principle of morality he's saying
there's something else that trumps these
there's something else that when it
comes down to it has to be made central
because of the kind of people that we
are you can always get it in two
complementary ways one is through this
concept of duty we have things that
we're supposed to do you all of you all
have experience of having things that
you feel a sense of obligation where
we're for instance you do feel guilty
right or when you do something that you
know is wrong you feel bad as well when
you do something that you know is a good
thing you often feel good don't you
those are our duties and we have a whole
set we talked about this with epictetus
and social roles so you have certain
duties as a result of being a son or a
daughter don't you where's your parents
you don't say yeah we're all adults now
screw you mod at the end never gonna
have anything to do with you I hope you
don't do that right let's think they'd
have to give you some really serious
claws to say something like that
what other duties do you have what other
roles I mean you're a citizen you can
say that you have a duty to vote we
don't actually require people in this
country some countries that do you all
sorts of duties all sorts of obligations
and often these are reveal to us through
our feelings like through admiration
through guilt or shame or through
sympathy or doing you how to start care
care for the other person but often
times we can understand these duties
just by things you can think what should
a good son or daughter be like what
should a good neighbor like and
sometimes you have duties because you
undertake introducing if I I didn't
actually have a duty to teach you Athens
until I signed the contract if we meet
on on the street I suppose it you could
say I have imperfect duty remember we
distinguishing perfect and imperfect
duties I have an imperfect duty to teach
you epochs if you run into me at
Starbucks across the street or
ten years later you're writing an email
and dr. Stadler I remember back in your
ethics class I and we talked about this
and I've got this moral quandary I'd
like some help with I'm not required
that it'd be a good thing right now I
have a duty to teach you and the reason
I hear that Duty is because I said I
would do it and I took some money for
you okay and I checked a box in an
electronic contract signing thing you
have all sorts of duties when you make a
promise you impose a duty hunter self
judge you have general duties like not
to lie to to harm people for no reason
along with this like God says goes
another concept the goodwill the
goodwill is the only thing he says that
is unqualifiedly good in itself and the
goodwill is the one that does Duty for
its own sake not just for the sake of
all these other things so there are
other values concept you could act in a
good way good in the fact that it's the
right thing to do
might even be beneficial to other people
it could be praiseworthy it could be you
know doing something like you know when
you give to charity for example or you
give your time to chair that's a good
thing to do right it could be the right
thing
for you to do it's certainly beneficial
to other people
it's praiseworthy we say this person is
doing a good thing good for them
people want some time to put in terms of
admiration why can't we be more like
these great philanthropists the thing is
OPA not saying for Khan as moral
goodness these are all kinds of goodness
but they're not goodness itself they're
not the title so all these can be
recognized but in some ways they're
besides the point if the goal is to be a
good person if the goal is to fill our
duties these things could be great but
they're not so one of the thing I know I
hit up as well is the connection between
reason and happiness this is a really
interesting set of remarks
so think about this let's let's assume
that there is some purposed events I
think most of us do you have a faculty
of reason right
we've talked about this quite a bit
thanks you're different from the other
animals you're still a man but you're a
rational and reasonable aoz you to do
things that a dog a chimpanzee an
elephant answer flyer in a man object
off you tosser
what is this good what's the purpose of
reason think about everything else why
do you have the instincts why do you get
hungry
what is your body making you do that
your body needs
by making hunger yeah and if you don't
feel a sense of hunger what's going to
happen yeah you're going to die you can
actually eat stuff and you're going to
die there's certain diseases that will
actually this cause a person to no
longer be hungry you know the cat for
example gets a cold cat then can't smell
its food and then the cat won't eat
because it's no longer attracted to the
food and this can be dangerous for cats
that are overweight because apparently
cats work a little bit differently less
you can't that's overweight and doesn't
deliver it will shut down in like one or
two days so if a cat is overweight it's
got a key B and if overweight cat gets
cold maybe you go on because the
instinct doesn't right we have all sorts
of we have all sorts of instance order
some other things that we desire by my
instincts if we move away from a lot of
painful things right touch a hot stove
and I did that when you're a kid you're
older quit doing that pretty quick right
did you ever put your finger in a
mousetrap just see what happened I did
that smart kid did you think you ever
like to give her up well what's
stay for my favorite yeah I'm purposely
listing what happened oh I get I think
so I did I mean it's far done I'm sure
some of us have had mishaps is super
glue to write nothing hey hi when I was
four years old I took a taxi and I
shoved it into an electrical log
so I guess I thought I was playing you
know start the car yeah I never did that
again there's all sorts of things we do
look right an instinct tells us okay
don't do that anymore avoid that Hey and
why's it did your body doesn't want to
die it will lets you to keep from from
killing yourself we feel thirst when we
need to drink water or other things I
suppose
the sexual urge is there in part to get
us to reproduce because if we don't
reproduce that's it you know everybody
became Sullivan in this generation be it
for the human race somebody's gotta
actually reproduce so there's all sorts
of things that we have by instinct and
couldn't we have been couldn't we have
had been implanted in us to make us do
the right thing well reason is given to
us why is it being given to us is it
being given to us and says is it being
given to us to lead us to happiness
maybe that's the purpose of reason one
right
yeah trusses pastels right was reason
given up given to us to make us figure
out what the right thing to do is so
that that would make us happy we can use
reason for that and you can calculate
utility you can work out your life plan
you can do all sorts of things like that
would that be the best way to set things
up if the whole goal was just to make us
happy which is for con to satisfy our
desires would have been smart for God or
nature or whatever whatever did it just
to set it up with the instinct if the
whole goal of life is just a maintenance
happy satisfy our desires well it could
be I mean sexual extremism to protect us
that gets us and lots of dangerous
situations doesn't yeah worry
or an instinct for curiosity leads us in
all sorts of I think like reasons
probably get into controlled instincts
and desires rather than necessarily if
you go you know any I think that the
would agree with you on that
and so Aristotle's would Freud right
counts is going to go even a little bit
further with this he says you know think
about it to begin the whole goal is just
to obtain what it is that we desire the
reason probably was not the best tool
for that bad job and he says if you
think about the way that people who have
designers try to satisfy them
they can sort of use reason to try to
maximize the satisfaction system we find
the more cup the more II cultivated
reason flies itself with deliberate
purpose to the enjoyment of life and
happens so much the more does the band
fail of true satisfaction we admit their
lies at the root of these judgments the
idea that our existence is different
this is an interesting thing far nobler
for which and not happiness reason is
properly intended says reason is not
competent to guide the will of certainty
in regards to its object the satisfying
or wants instinct would work better for
that
so what could reason be good for reason
is good for figuring out or Duty
actually this is something higher basis
yeah does this mean happiness is a bad
thing nobody should be happy always fill
your duty it makes you unhappy that's
even better
he's not saying that what he is saying
is that this is the goal of life to
really be fulfilled and your potential
as a person would mean being a morally
good person so that's very different
than other ethical theories is the other
states and won't worry enough when we
come back again to Aristotle on virtue
ethics this is going to be different
than virtue ethics this is even going to
be different than natural laws that's a
part of why we study this because it's
such a distinct position so what
actually is do
do you have a good
whenever you're reading is to do to
identify yourself there or other people
that you know
really
afraid to locate something's they may
they don't have a good well well let's
think about it this way do you have a
good will some of the time the way that
counsel talking boy you think he means
just once having a good will at one time
and then forget all the rest your life
no do you think he means that you have
to have a good will all the time unless
you're a perfectly good person all the
time you're a bad person morally you
make me sound it that way in your
reading it may have got that impression
Todd's not saying he's saying for any
given situation to do the morally right
thing it's going to involve having a
good will none of us are angels he says
none of us can a perfectly good will it
will that's never subject to temptations
it will always chooses the right thing
in and of itself if we did that there
wouldn't be any point to ethics were
there as a matter of fact the whole idea
of Duty is it says presupposes that
we're not perfect you wouldn't have to
be given duties if you were perfect you
just automatically do them if there
aren't angels then angels would be those
kind of beings one that
we're not like that we're sort of a mix
what makes a good will eject well is
that the person feels themself to have a
good will do you think there's a lot of
things that they're wonderful people
everybody should love them and then you
look at them you're like you're a
schmuck
look at what you do look at the ways you
mean so it's not just feeling that you
we had that is the goodwill the will
that produces good effects if we
rethought areas we would say the
goodwill is the one that brings about
happiness you know for the largest
amount of people right consequences Khan
says know what's really important here
intention it's the will that says a
goodwill is good not because of what it
performs or effects not by its campus
for the attainment of some proposed n
but simply by virtue of the volition
that is it is good in itself it's good
just because of the way it will the
volition is the will volition is just a
Latin word for will its usefulness or
fruitfulness can either add or take away
anything from this value it could be
good for other things but that's not
what makes it a good will so you know if
you're a good person and you have a good
will I'm going to like that aren't I as
a professor because what does that mean
you're going to do as a student you're
going to read you're going to be
conscientious and your writing you're
going to be you're gonna make things
very easy for me and entertaining
enjoyable right ask probing questions or
make a point every once in a while
you're going to write papers that what I
read is wow this is really insightful so
sometimes some of your papers I think
say things like this is a really great
example I'm going to use this next time
I teach this stuff right is that what
makes your will a good will the fact
that you please mean no not for comment
your will is good in itself and the fact
that it ends up pleasing me or pleasing
some other person or pleasing even
yourself
that's extra that's great that's not the
main dish itself so a good will how do
we know that I'm going to move ahead
what this goodwill would be so now we
get to another key idea of cons
so here curious how do we know what
makes a good really good will how do we
know what constitutes willing the right
thing it's going to be in accordance
with this Keith room duty so we have to
think about this idea of duty and what
is Duty I'm going to sort of go through
this very very quickly comments part he
says if we think about doing things that
we are obliged to do we have a moral
requirement either to do something or
not to do something and if we think
about our actions whether they're
consistent with duty whether they're
done from duty with their inconsistent
or contrary to do we can class them in
two different types so what are some
examples of the actions that would be
against things you're not supposed to do
and you're doing the wrong thing
yeah gee yeah so
we're all tempted everyone's for a lot
of Aegina I think and then we can say to
ourselves I have a duty not to cheat it
could be academically it could be
financially it could be interpreted
romantic relationships or all the ways
we cheat at cards except let's do play
cards any other ways we cheat you can
think of a camp where that concept makes
make sense
I mentioned academically right what
would be the opposite of that you have a
duty lesson then we have to specify it
like academically you have a minor code
you're supposed to follow what is that
code require you to do it I suppose the
planer is right what happens when I'm
not asked about the consequence what's
happening plagiarize what are you doing
this stealing people's work yeah this
that sort of a way to put it
what if somebody responds and they say I
didn't know I was stealing I was just
borrowing I mean what their work is
still they're still out there in the
journal in the website or something like
that I haven't taken it away other
people can still enjoy it what's what's
still wrong yeah
and I think your your on the key thing
of the second part pretending that
somebody else's work as your own so
you're putting forth something as if it
is your own after your own product and
you're being judged by it right because
we were grading there probably wouldn't
be an issue but we'd like when we grade
you for it to be your own stuff so it's
you do the frame it like this you have a
duty to do to your own work to present
your work and it for - it to be your own
not to be something else
now Connie has another example so we'll
start with that example then we'll come
back to this using your homework example
he talks about for instance a merchant
and I think you could generalize about
this a merchant has certain duties
towards their customers right this goes
to the cheating thing he talks about for
instance a baker and the baker has what
kind of duties you know things like
don't put rat poison in the bread but
you know we're not really focused on
that one
should the merchant overcharge a
customer who doesn't know the value so
this could actually be a real situation
but we're used to the price is feeding
clearly marked on things and if they're
not then we can actually like often take
it to a scanner and scan them [ __ ] up
with the prices we have gaps that can do
that on the phone if we have the UPC
code and stuff like that that's not
always the case and there's there's a
lot of items where it's difficult
with the true value it is you're going
to find this out more and more as you
start making more money and start having
more responsibilities when you start
going say to buy a house there's a lot
of way to research what the fair market
price of the house is but there's also a
lot of ways in which that could go go
loss or it's hard to get full knowledge
you know you have an inspection done
that's one way to make sure that you
know you're not going to have to sink
another 20,000 or you know 30 or 40,000
into fixing this thing the seller may
not disclose all of that to the real
estate person may not disclose all of
that to you they have an interest in
making sure that they get as much money
as possible okay for that property you
have an interest in getting a property
for a fair price so you can think of all
sorts of situations a merchant may be
tempted to overcharge simba if they
overcharge that person clearly
overcharging with the country to do when
we say that they have a duty to charge
everybody a fair price maybe not
necessarily to the same price maybe give
a sliding scale you know now that I'm an
adjunct I pay less for certain things
like it'll belong to certain
philosophical not making that much money
like I was a year ago I was a full-time
professor your students there's there's
a lot of things you can get a student
discount right that could be fair
why because are you making a ton of
money right now the students you're
probably actually spending more money
our ship
but the truck to overcharge is to not
charge a fair price that would be
contrary to right so charging a fair
price would be in accordance right does
that make it a morally good act as that
necessarily mean that there's a goodwill
there well what are the different
reasons
somebody might charge a fair price they
could have which would cause the actions
that could be an action that's in
accordance with duty but done because of
some immediate inclination the merchant
likes the person the cop is standing
right there watching to make sure that
you know nobody does it there's some
sort of immediate desires and feeling
something tangible that you can identify
with that would be in accordance with
duty
would that make it an action that's done
from duty or for the sake of duty or
come on put it another way because it's
the right thing if I don't want to
charge you but just because I like you
am i doing that because I recognize that
that's the right thing to do or am I
just motivated by the fact I love you if
I don't over charge you because you're
an enemy of somebody who's standing next
to to you have the counter and I hate
that other person who's standing next to
you at the counter
so I deliberately don't over charge you
like I normally would just because I
want to stick it to that guy because I'm
in overcharge him would that be actually
be motivated by a goodwill would be in
accordance with duty right but it
certainly wouldn't be done from duty
will be done to satisfy my inclinations
if I make a judgment you see this very
often made a claim make business Alex
it's smart to be a epical business
person why because it's going to improve
your bottom line because if people think
that you're ethical then they're going
to keep coming back to you if they think
you're unethical they're going to quit
being your customers if that's your
motivation are you you are acting in
accordance with yuni aren't you are you
acting out of duty or because that's the
right thing to do or are you doing it
for some other reason what do you think
ethical businesses smart businessman
bottom then from a Content perspective
that's not terrible yeah very good
yeah that's not to say that it's bad
this is bad
contrary to you right this is just sort
of indifferent it's better than you do
this but not to them to do this but it's
yet better it's it's on a different
level to be doing the right thing
because it's not doing the right thing
because it's going to make you happy
bringing benefits keep you off trouble
any of these other sort of moments let's
think about some other examples oh yeah
here is an interesting
all the waiting people say no or yes
right you don't follow us you're acting
contrary to duty do you have a duty to
follow the speed limit we're talking
about this one before
what if I expand it I say you have a
duty to drive no more than ten of those
people mostly say I can get that that
following speed look at this kind of a
pain is reflecting that most of us may
be probably least of all
but we recognize remember when we did
this slot experiment is there sort of a
limit that you shouldn't go past we said
yeah 10 a dozen out of it so you can
violate it you can be a reckless driver
that would be counter to duty there
would be a morally bad thing for count
why do most of us follow the speech line
I know I don't follow the speed limit
because I say the speed limit is a limit
which has been placed you know upon my
will to constrain it to only what is
within a safe you know range it's
reasonable I want to follow it this is
the right thing to do I don't think that
way
about the speed limit I should probably
if I'm conscious about that I don't
yeah maybe - more like transport
patients
okay that's a good question when you
have there is a duty that would
supersede we would say it supersedes
another duty you could frame this in
such a way that everybody should obey
the speed limit
everybody should drive within a
reasonable range of speed and then you
could say well what counts is reasonable
for most of us that's given by that sign
that sits there but if you are if you
have a legitimate purpose to drive
faster you know what what about if your
pregnant wife has gone into labor and
you got to get her to the hospital this
is a difficult pregnancy and all that
sort of stuff we would we would say that
I think count would also say in cases
like that you're talking about
exceptions that aren't really exceptions
because they fit within what the rule is
supposed to encompass that's a good
question yeah I mean there's there's a
lot of things like that something else
company so why do we have a the speed
limit may I tell you why why do you get
so hit as it gets Binnington speeding
tickets I have fun they cost you money
I don't for me it's even worse to have
to be stopped by the cop not because of
the embarrassment factors have stopped
you walking off in my life that that
goes away is that usually if I'm
speeding it's because I need to get
somewhere at a certain time to teach a
class I get pulled over I've only got
like a margin of five minutes usually
how long does it usually take
get pulled over on your those we have
been pulled over yeah I think that's
about right
you know so if I get below / that means
I don't show up for class and it means
class gets all off-kilter I think for
many of you it's probably more a matter
of money right not that I'm rolling in
money but me the time is actually does
anybody know Bay the speed limits they
feel good about obeys people we're to
all of you see it as an imposition
that's placed on you that you have to
obey because otherwise Johnny lots of
academic yeah
yeah okay I think that's a good case if
this actually goes to that question
about exceptions because you notice you
can drive the speed limit of the
weather's bad that might actually be
reckless its really snowing hard a lot
of traffic
maybe you should yeah maybe it was in
our case in that case confidence a you
are acting from the goodwill you are now
I will be doing your duty the way the
rest of us often do because you know we
don't want to get in trouble but because
it's the right thing to do
another good example doing your job
doing the job that your job job you get
paid everybody do the job that they get
paid for I'm not asking everybody in
here and all you do and your experience
is everybody do the job they're paid for
if you had experience of people who you
paid for a job that didn't do their job
right that would be wrong that would be
contraindicated there could be
gradations I mean if you pay a surgeon
to do an operation on you that's
probably a lot more serious than the
waiter doesn't bring you the water you
like it but it's still a counter to dude
can you do your job
just because you wanna get big sure I've
done a lot of jobs like that
that plenty of you have done jobs where
you're only interested doing that thing
was getting paid have any of you had any
jobs you really liked yeah you do the
work that's there because you like to do
that work you enjoy it you get something
out of it
guess what there's no moral worth for
that kind of it's still just in
accordance with duty it's done out of
some sort of inclination I think you'd
be willing to recognize that in some
sort of sense it's better to do your job
because you actually enjoy it and you
take pride than just because it Hey but
it's still at this month it's not doing
your job
solely out of the motivation of doing
your job nobody has ever done a job just
because it was the right thing to do I'm
going to bet someone remember those
experiences where the job was no longer
fun you're like man this is not worth
the money but I said I was going to do
this so I'm going to do it if that's
what what the case was that that's a
clear case of being motivated by duty
what were some other duties that you
yourself have you can pick up
what do you feel are your moral duties
could be a positive one you should do
this to the negative one yeah okay I
think that's a really good one
Wow let's let's narrow this down give it
a bit more in all the classes and this
is kind of interesting you feel that
this is a duty towards marriage college
or give you a blessing towards yourself
or maybe a duty towards somebody else
you didn't get good eating its course
yeah those are all those are all motives
for why one lots of viewers I'm asking
you a question that's before that was
this Duty extra towards if you do have a
duty I think all of you probably feel
that you have this is duty doing well
all in your classes right bear students
tend to be pretty Duty oriented pretty
you know self-motivated from my
observation is that in Duty you have
towards your parents well maybe whoever
else paid for your school a you got
government loans so therefore you have a
duty towards the government give duty
towards me with your professor or your
other professors where is the duty
religion or is yourself I think you may
think that towards me but usually after
duty as far as I can tell I don't think
you have a moral duty to do well in my
class towards me what do you think
you may feel - some of you feel that you
have a duty trust me there's a
difference between feeling something and
then sort of rationally thinking it out
you really have it you have other duties
towards me so I'm just as a human being
maybe some professor do you have a duty
towards me to do well in my class I
don't think you do
I think you feel it do I think that you
feel that you do because you've got
these long-standing patterns of feeling
a sense of obligation to those who are
in some way placed in authority over you
or have a classroom with something like
that but that's just from the habit
that's not that's not really that again
rational will is it towards yourself
yeah
I think primarily this is a duty this is
a duty you have towards yourself to to
make the most out of what you're being
given we're going to look at this a bit
more next class this is a really good
exam
now you could just break it and screw it
in a drink have as much fun as possible
sleep in playing xbox for this students
duties days right have all sorts of you
know boyfriends and girlfriends read
other magazines or websites as I'm
reading my playing my stuff that would
be contrary to you but would you be
letting up family yourself you'd be
letting yourself you can do it because
you are the cat person who really really
likes to study and you really get a kick
out of reading books and thinking about
them and discussing them if that's all
your that's the main reason why you're
doing it counted say that's in
accordance with duty but that's coming
out of your immediate inclinations it
doesn't have more work if you do it and
you push yourself even when you don't
feel like doing it because you think
this is the right thing for me to do I
have an obligation to do this I should
do this then you'd be giving the morally
right thing by doing your job as a
student I do too well in all of your
classes and that's not to say that if
you are the kind of student who actually
enjoys being a student and studying and
reading and thinking about things and
writing papers but that's a bad thing
it's stunning morally good the morally
good thing is to do it for the sake the
duty itself do you say
to improve my own mind I have to do it
through these classes
I wonder taken to do this I should I
should fulfill these obligations that I
have placed on myself now notice that
could be compatible you could actually
be the kind of student who enjoys what
they do and so it's less of an effort
for you to make yourself do that but if
you can still recognize that this is the
right thing for me to do but could you
and if you're recognizing that you're
not just sort of rationalizing your
desires and inclinations saying this is
the right thing to do is it's going to
pay off for me but you're recognizing it
as something that you ought to do
something that you have an obligation to
do during morally good person at least
insofar as you're doing this you see the
big difference between these yeah so
people who perform a duty to like
improve their own self reputation with
that beat it's a great question if the
goal is just to improve your reputation
we'll take a really concrete example
because I actually have some launch that
I have to actually
so what I've got here you guys some of
the other students what this actually
look like the person valuations what we
end up seeing when you guys fill out
those balls sheets this is what we
professors end up getting back it gives
us you know okay the instructor
professor effectively answer students
they show enthusiasm for the course that
maintain a positive attitude no okay now
if I do my job well I only have decent
numbers and these could be valuable for
all sorts of reasons it could be that I
get a kick out of looking at the numbers
si such a good professor oh I feel so
wonderful inside well that would just be
in accordance with that wouldn't be
these are all so valuable
I'm going to be applying for a job
pretty soon I'm going to send these a
warm these are part of my professional
reputation they want to see that I can
show up in a classroom and get good
numbers from the students more or less
you know we have a certain rate or he's
not terrible numbers at that you know
this is demonstrated effectiveness this
is part of my reputation if I'm only
acting on that basis I'm still only
acting in accordance with duty our tech
and you can think about this in a lot of
different ways that a child who does the
right thing when they're in school so
that they're seen as being a good kid
that's that's a matter of reputation the
professional who does the right thing
because they have to prove themselves
they're in a new town they want to be as
a doctor that everybody
those two again that was the reputation
so that would not be motivated solely by
doing that could be a goodbye Chronicle
I mean you could if you act in
accordance with you you may have as a
side effect the fact that you like what
you do or that it improves your
reputation or that you stay out of
trouble things like that editor pays you
well so the other things that we
acknowledge is goods may come to you
from doing your duty if the world is set
up right they will come to you how well
do you think the world is set up it
comes to that in your experience what do
you think
the World Fair in general that those who
do their duty not just to get other
stuff for their own sake as you've seen
people do this do they end up always
getting the right pay off or the
sometimes get taken advantage of screw
around yeah
whether you're taking that do you think
they get taken advantage of more in this
world then then those who cover the last
day they do things that are in
accordance of Duty 4 just because it's
going to bring about dozen to make sure
that everybody knows I'm doing this
because I want the money I'm getting
this because I reputation what do you
think if you had to guess like what is
your gut time I feel like if someone's
doing or anything good because they want
you to write they may say it added up
use other people and see that I think
you're right that conforms to my
experience maybe be maybe you and I
maybe I have the rusty relate to that
tune maybe we've grown up in
environments where things were not set
up that well for people who did do Duty
for their own sake a lot of them get
taken advantage of maybe there's other
cultures where that's less the case I
don't know yeah
that's true
yeah and maybe there's actually a duty
somewhere online to do that as well dig
deep down it may be difficult to fulfill
all one's duties you might have to
choose count doesn't over talk about
this you may have to choose which duties
you're going to actually try to fulfill
at any
do you have it don't eat anything drink
well as a matter of fact you do because
you have a duty to yourself a lot or you
might say to care I think some of the
personal hygiene has put in there when
you have to do with this - I mean if you
don't take showers ever you put yourself
at a great risk for dying I mean it
might not and you know it's not a
service people won't like it or smell or
something like that it's that you can
actually get sick right remember when I
was in the Army there was always like
one guy in every unit who would not take
showers and the rest of them after a
while would grab him and throw him
bodily into the shower and it can take a
shower and the drill sergeants were like
that's good because otherwise this guy
is going to get sick you know was one
just a matter stinker you have to eat
you have to drink in it I guess if you
get sick you also need to take your
medicine there's a lot of things you
need to do to stay alive you can't just
walk out into 9w anytime you please
right Sean across the street you should
probably wait until the light turns red
and the walk side comes out otherwise
you're putting yourself at risk now do
we have it do we have a lot of instincts
to sort of take care of this
yeah is that enough to keep people a lot
people do dumb things from time to time
what can't really hasn't mind
he's going to talk about this a bit more
in the next chapter people kill
themselves don't they when they do that
why do they do that usually just for fun
I don't know anybody
I don't know just although there was a
philosopher yeah there was a philosopher
Michel Foucault who deliberately got
himself AIDS which is kind of strange
thing to do in the 80s when first coming
out he deliberately went out and got
himself infected with AIDS to experience
what it was like there seems to me
incomprehensible he had some sort of
justification but it's really foot you
know
Devon compensated that guy did something
wrong
Kahn would say you have a duty to
preserve your life just like you have a
duty to preserve other people's life you
are a person you count so you have duty
and you can either do what's contrary
it's wrong for you to kill yourself Kahn
sense this is where you know like a day
at ologist this is their response to
things like euthanasia counts that you
can't participate morally wrong can you
keep yourself alive just because it
never occurred to you to do anything
else the mail sure we've been doing this
in the whole time right I hope none of
you have been like actively weighing and
every single morning maybe the day I
kill myself now I think we'll go on
another day hope not right for you
another question would it like I have
why we have to do why do we have to keep
our cell phone we're just a little bit
more next class we look at the
categoric imperative the short answer is
that to not do that would be sort of
like to misuse what but we're going to
pull her hands
together so I mean you know it was a
common thing back in Greek and Roman
days for people to do it if they felt
totally ashamed that he'd killed himself
the great warrior Ajax did one of
Sophocles plays kills himself the people
who are on the outs after Caesar wanted
the power stronger struggled they slit
their wrists late in the bathtub Khan
would say that that was that was wrong
to do so we're going to get some wine as
a second yeah I was going to say I feel
like comp the only time that potentially
we would even consider filling yourself
would be in the case of a sacrificing
your life yes then you wouldn't be
killing us right rather than just going
and killing yourself
he basically no reason is large enough
unless you're doing it to save others or
create something bigger better than
killing yourself with the idea that all
the pain you've been feeling will go
away and to do that would be to be
fulfilling dude restaurants yeah but if
only also doesn't want you to like why
that's true and what if you're lying
eight millions of people okay so what
anything about what if we added a
dilemma where either you lie or you kill
yourself or you don't tell a lie you
stay alive and no eggs of people suffer
as a result
one way to not have to lie or to give
them give away
nation of it would result in all these
deaths would be to coach the only way
out of this to kill yourself that's a
tough one I have to think about it
my immediate thought on that is that
cotton would say you would be fulfilling
another duty to not allow all those
other people to be harmed but I think a
strict conscient would actually say that
now what I have to think about moving on
with maybe some of the soul oh you keep
yourself alive
you know you morning the cereal you do a
little exercise maybe walk to class get
out of class go out another meal stop at
the drinking fountain drink some water
take a shower all these sorts of things
and you do that not necessarily out of
duty you do it in accordance with you
you do it because you like being alive
right I'll be like being alive the thing
if you ever get to the point you really
don't like being alive that might get an
issue of doing it out of duty or because
of where you say to yourself I'd like to
tell myself this is mrs. waffle what I'm
experiencing but I have a duty not to
kill myself and I'm going to honor that
Duty even though I'm not happy about it
even though it doesn't bring me
happiness I'm going to do it because
it's the right thing
that would be acting out of duty rather
than just in accordance with food it
could it be possible to do both of these
yeah it could be possible
but you're always going to be tempted
context to rationalize acting on the
basis of what you would like to do what
would make you happy
into your duty and not do duty for its
own sake that do what you want to do in
some sake let's use a different example
let's think about the one that I've
brought up a couple of classes with this
losing previous and ongoing link will
make it really you know really stark I
won't just be boyfriend or girlfriend
over to your spouse so assume that
you're here right
assume that if you're a woman you had
previous you know boyfriends or I
suppose to and if you're if you're a man
you know the opposite you're now married
to somebody and let's say what video I
let's say you got three that you're
actively involved with in your life one
of them is in your workplace one of them
goes to the same gym that you do at the
same time and one you're still good
friends with you haven't told your
spouse about this previously
because you have me have that that talk
you might say well why did you get
married before let's just assume they
did okay sometimes these things do you
have a duty to reveal let's say you do
actually let's say you actually want to
I think most of you came to the
conclusion that you probably ought to
reveal these sort of things to your
spouse yeah the relationship is like
completely over and you don't talk to
them no you do talk to you know you're
not involved in romantically but you are
involved with one in the workplace one
of the gym and one year Matt in fact you
have dinner parties and this person
comes with their new
boyfriend/girlfriend to the dinner
prompts well then that's probably why
you want to disclose it to your spouse
right so they could say maybe your
committee your spouse would say that's
it for the dinner parties we don't want
that person around let's focus on the
duty to reveal that information if you
don't reveal that information you're
acting contrary to the duty right now we
talked about reasons why it might be a
good thing for you to reveal that
information what are some of those
reasons yeah yeah if you don't do that
and then it comes up at the dinner party
hey back when so-and-so and I were
dating and then your spouse their jaw
drops they're like what the hell is that
because they drop the plate like out of
a movie
now you're you have some problems right
so you know you could you could do you
could reveal the information you could
fulfill your duty because you don't want
to seem like that you don't want the bad
consequences for somebody like me is
always talking all the time anyway
I would reveal that information but just
because I like telling people about
things and you know my spouse is there
to hear my stories she she on occasion
says you know you've already told me
that
and you know she doesn't say that bad at
first I thought it was like a shot but
it's not am i doing it for the right
reason I'm revealing it because I like
telling stories again it's in accordance
with duty but it's not how to do it
could be a good thing to do I mean being
prudent and not covering things up so
that you don't have a big scene later on
that's a smart thing to do it's not the
morally right thing to do in the sense
of being done out of duty if on the
other hand you said your song I love
this person I have all these duties
towards them this is really something
that I want to disclose to them I think
I have a strict duty here I'm not going
to like doing this because maybe they're
going to say you can't hang out with
this person anymore
or you know no more conversations with
that or something like that but it's
really the right thing for me to do that
would be acting out of duty or because
of doing that would be the morally right
thing that would be to act with the
goodwill you can see the difference
there there's a fundamental difference
for for cut between doing what would
work out well for us or as fruited to do
or keep us out of trouble or would pay
off well or keep us from feeling guilty
and doing the right thing because it's
the right thing what about other
disclosures yeah that if I were that
fast I would want to know so out of
respect I think that's a good way to get
it to the
of being this to think of how count
doesn't frame it like this but thinking
about how the other person would see it
I think would be a good way of leading
yourself to doing ecology nothing did it
just because that could go wrong because
you could say yeah my hope my spouse is
really high strong really easily hurts I
don't like what my spouse gets hurt
because then they don't talk to me or I
feel bad or something like that again I
would still not be acting out but if you
were to stay my spouse deserves my
respect what would be doing it out of so
what about other things maybe this will
be an issue for some scrolling conflicts
of engines if you're a business or walk
and even medicine conceivably some other
things too you may have conflicts of
interest and you have to disclose you
have a legal obligation or a fiduciary
obligation to disclose you may it I
would say that you probably have a moral
obligation in those cases to disclose
them certainly if you have a legal
obligation if the right thing to do is
closed because the law says you should
do it but even if the law doesn't tell
you you have to couldn't there be some
cases where you really want to disclose
that you are involved with the case
somehow yeah like in the field that I'm
going to try a lot it right particularly
yeah I kind of already have an issue is
me and my girlfriend are going to
for competing firms start yeah you have
to reveal it right right and then a
couple of the clients which we have like
I know people who work at those
companies which are required to reveal
because I can't practice they don't not
audited yeah but then why is that the
case
we want the water to be fair now why we
got if you don't reveal the information
that's contrary but what are the
different motives you could have for
we're afraid of getting in trouble
you're afraid to get a cloth probably
should be yeah a priest can't go to
police and break the seal the confession
yeah psychiatrists have some things
yeah but what's the one told you to be
killed
officially a priest can't the way the
rules about confession errs was worth
priest isn't supposed to say anything
about that
the psychiatrist's good well don't the
cops like they they would never I think
that it's so legal for them who I pulled
the information because they are sworn
for their listen great if you're but
like law enforcement
you can't faculty rates for withholding
yeah I think God would not be himself
sympathetic to that sort of clerical
privilege I think kind of probably
reason one of the lines that the way
it's worked out is that it's usually on
there are so increasing to have revealed
information
sort of ways on there I don't know much
about that I have friends for priests
but how do you decide but that's a
little bit different than this this is
where you have information you have why
why would you reveal what are some other
reasons for me you might be for others
and maybe yeah what are some other
moments I mean that the idea that you
want processes to work fairly I think
that would you like a mission of duty
with them right if you were to say
something like well works a lot better
for everybody in the long run you don't
think that's duty I think that's looking
at consequences not at the sheer
ripeness of video that's looking at a
more utilitarian and damn logical again
maybe you just like revealing things to
people you get a kick out of that well
that's your main reason for doing it
then you're acting in accordance with
you're doing the right thing I'm certain
sense but you're not doing it for the
right reasons so your action is not
morally good it's just a right action
it's not at the higher level how can we
tell this goes to your question how can
we tell what our duties actually higher
think about that let's think for a
moment about different duties that you
have what are what are duties that you
feel what is if you feel guilty if you
didn't do okay notice cam started
popping up as soon as I sort of framing
it just as what duties do you have it so
what do you feel guilty about
everybody's got one right go to class
what's up yeah right
come on I work when you're not sick okay
oh wait that's only you should write
signing your duty is to go play or not
to not to why things our understanding
with that may be doing other things too
and having to do with personal hygiene
Oh mister that's a bare minimum yeah
okay let's go bury the khalsa what's
that work out what else do ya students
eat what are some things you feel are
moral to these yourself returns any
people call your mother touch okay
that's very broad thank you I think
it'll be part of it what do you mean
look we may get a few out of this
so keeping promises what else do you
mean by responsibilities okay
what's up let me actually say something
to here's sort of a digression I may
have said before when we're teaching
ethics we're teaching these moral
theories for you it's kind of abstract I
think and you may get the impression
that you know so they hate ethically is
just to like you know here's your moral
theory alarm and now you just apply your
I agree million is going to go
swimmingly but really I think that one
of the big tests for athletes whether it
really does anything is how it helps you
fix things after you screwed a lot
because your life like everybody else's
is going to be a series of successes and
a lot of failures and some of those
failures are going to be moral failures
and then the question is how do you pick
up the pieces after you've thoroughly
screwed things up do you screw them up
even worse but how you trying to get
yourself on that situation or do you end
up you know for instance owning up to
take responsibility right you take
responsibility and then start doing what
you need to do to fix it that's an
ethical choice and that's one of the
kind of you're going to face probably
until you die it sounds a little
pessimistic but really this is very comp
to missed this means that even when
things get really bad and you know be
managed to mess something up there's
still room for fixing things and there's
still good choices and bad choices to
make yeah it's going to be a
there's a lot of comedians make the joke
about lying to get out of a lie with it
yeah actually that's a good example of
the issue of taking responsibility if
there's there's like whole sitcoms based
around that premise where somebody tells
one small line and now instead of
actually taking responsibility and
saying I live for 30 minutes they tell
another lie to cover that line and
pretty soon the whole house of cards
comes down I'll tell you about the funny
story another very short digression aid
a friend one fortunately died is pretty
young I don't know what he would be like
now but when he was you know like
college age even high school he was you
know him two or three girlfriends and
deaf might not have been that the
problem if they'd all been okay with
that and known about each other but they
didn't know about each other because he
would invariably start lying to them and
the first couple times that this
happened
we'd watch this guy and he'd be like boy
you're screwing up we would think that
he sort of knew what he was doing you
know some sort of reason for it after a
while we came to realize no this is just
a cat person that he was and so
invariably what's going to happen sooner
or later you're going to tell the wrong
line of the wrong person because it's
hard to keep track of lies he was
certain he knows anyway that all house
of cards falls down the two girls were
three girls we'll find out about each
other and they're never happy about that
okay
and then he without any girlfriends for
a while and then you know he start
dating another girl and then with him
you know like a month of dating a girl
he start dating another girl the weird
really weird thing about it was so he's
always cheated and he would cheat on a
good-looking girl with a girl who was
less good-looking and if he had a third
she'd be
Remiel er what's going on in here it was
like just the impulse to like she maybe
was a power thing yeah what's up and
even think you know I don't know we
never did get really figured out but
after a while we realized this is just
the way it is so let me just kind of sit
back and watch the show because we knew
sooner or later he was gonna get caught
it relies and you know the whole house
of cards again like I said tumbling down
okay although we're not hearing us
recover for anything usually but yeah he
could have done things differently he
could have at one point said wow this is
screwed up I need to change my life he
never did maybe now he was 42 years old
he would have changed his ways but that
takes a moment where you actually take
responsibility for who you are the
conditioning so I think this is a really
good example of a duty owning up to what
you've done this is one that you might
say is required to make morality
so you've got all these different duties
right are there different reasons you
can do this let's some of these are
things that probably wouldn't consider
to be really major duties some of them
would be imperfect duties I'm going to
be perfect duties
let's take not lying about your set
first off if you lie about being sick
that's not doing the right thing right
that's this going against your duty
we've gone your boss we say hey look
second we're really out you know going
someplace
you just didn't feel like even coming
into work that's the wrong that goes
against what motives might for some
campers for not being posed with the
situation so cash and I guess having if
you have a certain amount of page that
you can do that having an extra one when
you really need it
yeah it could be prudence and that's a
good example you don't turn up your sick
days you person them you're affecting
the people that are working that day
okay you don't want to put your
co-workers operating um all of your
money about you're not going to work you
think about if you need the money okay
that's a good point - yeah
I think next time I actually get out
yeah so none of these are all good
Prudential reasons why you shouldn't lie
about being sick to get out of work it's
almost like that
some of them are almost like that story
about a little boy who cried wolf you
guys all remember that one
don't you no don't lie all the time
because I'm if you do people are going
to believe you not going to have the
credence when you need it you may need
the sick days you need the money all
those those are good reasons compensated
or not they're not reasons that make it
a moral Act so what would be required
would be to see that as your duty and to
do that just because it's your do not
because not not being motivated by all
these over
categorical imperative is a way of
thinking about how we can tell whether a
reaction czar actually in accordance
with and motivated by do so it's kind of
like a and Khan says that we should
react
so we're going to other formulations and
this is kind of jargon this will
something to be a universal law of
nature that means you can universalize
it you can say this would be the right
thing to do for everybody so if you know
to take a really silly trivial example
I like coffee if drinking coffee has
morals worth that means that everybody
ought to drink coffee across the board
clearly that can't be something that has
moral worth drinking coffee right
because doesn't that seem kind of silly
to say that everybody wants to drink
coffee what if I say something like this
though when you're buying a product
everybody ought to buy products that are
Fairtrade meaning that the workers are
receiving a fair wage could that be
universalized could you say that that's
something everybody want to do that
would make sense of a world in which
everybody does that you could and you
can actually will what I want to focus
on today is not so much the categorical
imperative itself I want to focus on
let's notice this word maxim now if you
had associate that with because
something today was it would be the
first thing that comes to your mind
probably a men's magazine right Maxim
which tends to have scantily clad women
on it and focus on how to date people
consumer products and celebrities and a
few other things it's mostly kind of a
flop night sort of like the younger man
is GQ it which is also fluff pegs
maxim has a older sense so max is a sort
of generalized
give you an example you guys all
remember that famous John Kennedy quote
ask not what your country can do for you
ask what you can do for your country
so you know you gave that big speech
about the Peace Corps and all that sort
of stuff that's an example with Maxim is
it saying you know you ask what your
country can can do for you over you know
it's supposed to apply generally across
the board right and you can make up
Maxim's that correspond to your actions
so I'm going to cheat on my next test
you can turn that into a maxim you know
whatever a test I'm going to cheat on it
I should you done it I will she died you
might actually start looking more
closely at what's going on because
remember that thing that we had before
with attention leads in action
maxim has to do with the action and the
attention when you describe it an action
moral action you can describe it in
terms of what it is the person to do is
cheating a test right
you can also describe it in terms of the
consequences passing the class or
something like that left but you can
also talk about the intention what is
the intention to do better on to get
better grades to make it through a tough
semester you can think of all sorts of
motives why a person might cheat on a
test right what why do people cheat or
think about plagiarism why do why do
most students end up plagiarism is it
because they stay you know stay up late
at night thinking how can I screw the
system I'm going to be a bad student
figure out how to steal people's work
that's right I mean there may be a few
students up there play around just
because they enjoy plagiarizing but I
think most students why do they play
because there's really two main causes
one is they don't know they're
plagiarizing usually that's their own
fault because we explain for
plagiarizing consistent but what's the
other reason they run out of hi-yah
thing you can never have enough and then
they say god I got to get something done
I don't want to flunk the class I don't
have enough time to actually come up
with this myself this looks pretty good
over here I think I can put this into my
own paper and you know maybe it'll get
fly
so the general lines rule in a case like
that might be whatever I don't have the
time or resources to do it myself I will
Kasilof somebody else's work as my own
that could be a maxim right think about
self-defense if somebody breaks into
your I don't know if the walls are here
in New York I know this was a student
that you know we're in for the kind of
place where you could actually engage in
use of deadly force for self-defense
somebody breaks into your house and you
go into the kitchen and get off the
butcher knife and you confront them kill
what is the maxim involved there
whenever I'm threatening illegitimately
by somebody in my own house
I will use deadly force to protect
myself and my family
notice that doesn't just apply to me
that would apply it you would be saying
whenever anybody is threatened in their
own house they use deadly force to repel
the intruders so if you can make up a
general rule notice - that doesn't have
to do just with the action that tells
you why the action is being done because
if we change the attention we would
change the mass what if I said whenever
somebody breaks into my house I will use
deadly force because I get a kick out of
stabbing people is that the same it's
the same action right static oh is it
the same action overall given the
intention what do you think in one sense
it is the same action right same
physical events are taking place but the
description of what actually is
happening wouldn't be the same this
person is indulging themselves in
violent fantasy
pick whatever you like we want to
describe them as being what with an
aggressive sin that's not the same thing
that you see right at this repelling and
intruder by using force when you have to
that's not the same thing as liking to
stamp people you know an intruder
happens to come along and you give it to
them you see the difference there they
would have different Maxim's you can
think of a maxim as a way of describing
let's think of a few other Maxim's a few
other situations where this could come
up one great example I brought this up
last class is abortion somebody goes do
you have an abortion how might we
actually describe that action and assume
this let's say three people go into an
abortion clinic they've all they're all
doing the same reaction like they have
different intentions might they be
motivated in different ways
what were the reasons people see advised
other people see you know pay for why
why do people go to abortions so maybe
that can be an issue
mother I won't think about some glass
that's what that that's one where we go
go yeah there could be a good reason
what's what's a bad reason an abortion
yeah yeah baby you a person style and
then what might give a tougher
it's our middle road
okay let's say first okay
some countries I can be just being a
girl would we describe these would we
use the same Maxim to describe each of
these let's take the convenience I just
don't want to be I'm a man so in my case
would have to be something like I get
the woman pregnant I bring pressure on
her and say we don't really want to baby
this is going to crimp our style it's
going to cut into our finances remember
we're going to go on that trip next
month and we don't even know if we stay
together right
my generalized rule that I'm using there
is something like whenever it is
inconvenient with me I will terminate a
pregnancy right is that the same thing
as whenever the health of the mother is
threatened and it's even make it a
little stark it's guaranteed that she's
going to die she gives birth
whenever the health of the mother is
threatened she would all fourth the
pregnancy is that the same thing as
whenever it's inconvenient with me I
will avoid pregnancy very different
batches they may have a different moral
evaluation we'll look at this next class
I will use this example again next class
they may have very different evaluations
from a conscient perspective so that's
where we'll end
the categorical imperative is a way of
thinking about any given action or
choice that you would you would be
making we're not going to go fully in
because we're going to do that more next
class
the first formulation of it is something
along these act always the maxim or
another way of thinking about this it
would make sense to say that everybody
should should act this way so we'll talk
about maximum just a second if you want
to think about an action is the right
action to do where is the wrong - can
you universalize can you say everybody
should act this way so lying to your
spouse about previous partners you
probably can't universalize it you know
would it makes sense to conceive of a
world in which everybody makes out their
practice in which that's what you what
you all do then the institution of
marriage starts to break down start
importing that much deception so that
wouldn't really work can you say
everybody should review and you can I
mean there would be some consequences
people probably wouldn't lie
it does make sense that everybody should
response this is the one word I think in
here that you probably saw you're like
what is that what does the match maxim
is something like a general rule so I
will show up to class on time that's
about me right everybody should show up
to class on time now we're at the level
of the minute it could also be expressed
in usually I will show up to class on
time whatever I'm supposed now it's more
just I'll show up to class I will show
up to class on time
next Tuesday that's kind of specific
isn't it that's less gentle if we think
about a actions remember how we did this
skewing equal reaction and intention or
motive then consequence and
utilitarianism started with this and
then sort of work its way backward Conte
is interested in the action itself and
action it is and even more in the
intention that a maxim is going to be a
foul this portion and ignore the the
actual consequences so let's let's take
the killing yourself because life is
profound
say because of shame people kill
themselves because they're bullied
sometimes high-profile issue
cyberbullying people kill themselves
right they they say why why do they do
it because they feel this overwhelming
sense of shame vulnerable all the time
and the life sort of gets more and more
constrained and eventually they say I
can't live like this
so Maxim in a case like that would be
when my life becomes unbearable I will
end my life now notice there's there's
there's more involved than just the
action you can look at actions in a lot
of your ways if a person kills themself
by say taking an overdose of some sort
of medication there's the physical
action of taking all the medication
there's a consequences the physical
effects that happen the broader
description of the action is something
like ending their own life killing
themselves with warfarin suicide right
but the intention is important - is it
it could be a different after the
different Maxum depending on the
intention if the attention one one
second
if the intention is to get away from an
unbearable situation that's a bit
different than ending your own life to
save a hundred other people's luck we'll
use the example that we had before we
would have a different sort of that's
description of the action and you can
say look it's the same it's the same
action killing yourself but the motive
is different
what about killing yourself just to say
screw you some people do that or what
about you know setting yourself on fire
to protest your country being invaded
because this is a sort of tradition
potential protest here from Vietnam well
I'm thinking about that death of a well
that happens in Vietnam - right but
recently it's been happening - that is
that the same action I mean the kill
oneself is the same but the motive is a
bit different I think there would be a
different max if the maximum is
something like whatever my life becomes
intolerable I will use my resources to
end my life
that's one max if the situation is a bit
different you say in order to save
countless others I will lay down my own
life
that seems to get a different mansion
doesn't it so it's very important to
figure out how we should describe the
action its have like a ten commandments
and actually their list of actions that
we have followers anybody create their
own if any time that's a good question
so it's like I can justify anything by
saying this is my intention well that's
where some of these testers like
universal law there's some things you
can't make it to to universal laws and
the other formulation of categorical
spirit that we're going to look at says
that you should always treat humanity
never as as a means but always as an X
so there are certain things that you
couldn't rationalize or justified
yourself just by having the attention
then I go back to the other to the
question this Connie hops were like a
master list like the Ten Commandments
yes but not in this this work this is
the groundwork for the metaphysics of
morals
Robert think of like a basement or
foundation
another way of translating this
foundation it's not the whole of the
house he does have another work called
the metaphysics of morals and that's
divided into metaphysical elements
virtue and then metaphysical elements of
justice and there he gets a lot more
specific here he gives you some general
rules to actually three formulations of
the categorical imperative and then it
would be up to you to apply he doesn't
actually give you everything could
possibly use he doesn't give you a
comprehensive code
is everything because he thinks that
there will be a lot of situations where
you would want to actually step back and
apply a rule sort of like this because
there's going to be things that he's
never thought it's a good question
yeah let's let's actually get a little
bit early
got the general idea of maxim's how to
mount it understand captions
we'll get some examples later